welcome back to new rockstars one
division is finished we're all still
recovering
but we still have questions like where
was dr strange
jessica and i are gonna evolve our wanda
the
call out to wtf or wizard stuff
this is all about doctor strange and how
he just dipped out
we're now asking dr strange uh all of
our questions
because he's the only one who's gonna
have the answers i think
this is inside marvel it's our one
division post season
wrap-up episode i'm eric boss here with
jess clements how you doing jessica i'm
doing good
i'm more excited to talk about where we
think this is gonna go and with like
we've had a week since the last episode
so now we can talk about like
what we thought about before we went to
bed every night and how
some of it made no sense to me so i was
like it can only go this way in the
future
we needed a couple days to digest
everything we were throwing a lot
and now on the other side of those days
i i feel like i have a better idea of
what the answers to these questions
might be a little bit
um really as more and more time goes by
the more this aftertaste of this
meaningful series blossoms into a
truly satisfying flavor i just ate uh
cobb salad with like thousands oh we get
it you're better than us
i refuse to eat a cobb salad that's
rabbit food
mister squishy it does feel like
and folks this is new rockstars we're
always going to dig deeper into
everything
so before we move on from one division
we want to do our best to try to answer
so
try to address some of these lingering
questions you might have had oh and by
the way a lot of you have been asking
jess has been such a delight to co-host
this one division after show with and
jess
you are gonna be a regular face on new
rockstars going forward yeah
uh we can officially announce that uh we
know that you're a very very busy person
so but whenever uh you can you're gonna
be here
you guys are gonna see a lot of jessica
going forward tommy
and you co-hosted yes yesterday's big
question it was so
funny don't talk about it i love it
i love time i feel like there's been two
different times where i've talked about
this big question and i'm like
i'm so sorry everybody and we go off the
railings a couple of times but then i'm
like
i'm like it's me and tommy if me and
tommy had a show forever it would be
that
episode of big question and well and i
would watch it forever i'm going to
re-watch that episode
because there's so many it's so many
laughs it's a laugh a second
it's it's educational and funny because
some of those things you probably didn't
know the us did which is
bad [ __ ] insane well literal bat [ __ ]
insane that bat bomb project x yeah
literally literally babies and as we
always start off i
am wearing uh a new rockstar shirt this
is nr but we had our latest obsession
shirt
i'm not wearing it now because it is in
the laundry i wore it too much it
smelled too bad kelly just
had to tear it off me i was like ooh
what are we doing and she's like no i'm
just doing this laundry that's it
you have to watch this but it's a great
shirt uh
you can still get your hands on we are
almost sold out but one of the added
benefits of getting that shirt is that
you could write in a custom shout out
that will appear at the bottom of
inside marvel episodes so looking down
what do we got we got styles sanderson
said i'm super bummed we probably won't
be getting mephisto
but i will die on this hill with you
boss we
might we are going to get in because i
have theories on how he's also going to
come back it's just not here
it's not now oh yeah yes i agree i agree
oh also iman uh hassan says
what if when a wanda rewound time in one
division that rewound time
outside too so the beekeeper never went
in
at all uh we have some ideas about the
beekeeper i don't know if she could
rewind time
outside i would say that everything she
did only went as far as the hex
until one of those things went outside
the hex so maybe this guy like tennant
was permanently reversed
after he went out the head and he's just
reversing back benjamin button style to
his baby hood
oh and then he dies the cutest thing on
the planet
and then uh sadie molina says daniel
nieves omg look we made it on the new
rockstars i love you 3 000.
that's right you guys are here well done
and thank you for supporting us
all right jess what is the first big
wizard the [ __ ]
of the season that we never got answered
i also have to remember to say wizard
the [ __ ]
instead of wanda that's fine if you
forget if i say that just
yes correct me uh wizard the didn't dr
strange help wanda
he dipped out yeah he was not there and
i think
the reason this is weird is that agave
could sense the
the magic of the west view hex and she's
a sorceress
yeah the sorcerer's supreme you think
would be able to sense this
jess what was your idea you said that dr
strange might have been dealing with a
bigger threat right
i said that earlier and then upon
thinking about it longer
um i was so yeah at the beginning i was
like i think he's just dealing with a
bigger threat because this is something
that's just taking over new jersey which
i understand there's a lot of people in
this town
but at first it's just like what imagine
what he was doing in the first doctor
strange movie and then
what wanda was doing in new jersey you
think he would have stopped what he was
doing saving the world
to stop wanda in new jersey like that it
just seems like he's busy doing
something else but
now i'm starting to think um i'm looking
down at my nose because i wrote down
what i think all the things are
so we have so let's talk about this
really quick um
just to help me with my doctor strange
because i rewatched it recently
mordo is now like mordo has have reached
his villain peak right
he's gonna be in doctor strange too we
think he might be like
a super villain we don't know uh if he's
reached his villain peak uh he's
he ended doctor strange saying too many
sorcerers and he's he looks like a kind
of guy who's going to rid the world of
other sorcerers so i think he
is going to try ridding the world of
wanda and doctor strange
too and i think kind of like how jane
grey
and like professor x are like no you can
control it i think it's going to be
doctor strange and wanda
but wanda is going to be like no i don't
care about you
to dr strange because she also has still
has agon she still has agatha
so she can just zip her back to agatha
and be like tell me how i can
float this man through space forever
like she can just ask her oh my god
that's not what she's he's doctor
strange he'll be fine but um i think dr
strange is gonna try to be like mordo's
gonna come and kill you if you don't
like
stop acting crazy not crazy but if you
stop
doing what you're doing and mordo's and
she's gonna be like i'm not afraid of
mordo like i'm scarlet witch
and then so i think that's what it's
like we're setting it up for is him
showing up in the like don't like it's
going to start the movie with that
that's okay i think like timeline-wise
so you're thinking like uh doctor
strange has sensed that he just hasn't
gotten here yet he just he missed the
train
the train door is closed in front of him
and he's like dang it i'm not gonna be
able to get there in time to stop it
mcu does that like where the movie's
gonna start five minutes
like five minutes after wanda and he's
gonna be like
i need to get over there it's the kind
of classic thing of like he
was in the process of helping the camera
just wasn't pointed on
yeah no i think uh a lot of us have like
kind of uh what's it called peekaboo
syndrome where it's like i don't see it
so it doesn't exist
but it's just like things can be
happening and then as soon as we just
show that scene
and doctor shane's shoe i'll be like oh
that's why that makes sense
it doesn't help the fact that he can
still he can still see it though
because that is the thing like he knows
all probability so it's like
right theory oh and you know what that's
that that's a good point jessica because
a lot of people are saying that doctor
strange might have foresaw this
back in infinity war that you know he
looked out into the futures using the
time stone
and we don't know how far into the
future he could have looked beyond
thanos's defeat yeah and it was only a
couple weeks later that he was seen this
other
big event of what the scarlet witch was
doing
so maybe he saw all the way to that and
he's like
no part of my plan needs to be to set up
wanda maximoff to become the scarlet
witch so he kind of set things in motion
and he intentionally did not make it so
that vision could come back
and that's why he let thanos go all the
way to getting the mind stone out of his
head
so that vision is dead uh wand is
heartbroken
wanna becomes the scarlet witch has this
other weird resetting plot i know it's
convoluted but doctor shooting this
plane is already convoluted
it's convoluted but it's so simple like
in writing and also in theory that like
for the comic book world
where you can just say well he probably
saw this coming and needed it to happen
we would have still had wanda maxum off
but now we have scarlet witch the
strongest person in the world
uh so he definitely probably saw and was
like i'm not gonna stop this from
happening
i need this to happen right so he's uh
he has been this is all pre-scripted for
him that wanda would flip out like this
and create this hex and then yeah
uh re resurrect vision in some weird way
uh
through i guess it was hayward and sword
who kind of pieces back together
uh but white vision's still around and
he now has his memories unlocked so
i feel like uh history might have gone
the way dr strange wanted and that's why
he didn't interfere
with the probability factor it might
make sen it might make more sense that
like the major villain
if it is mephisto if it shows up in dr
strange's second movie
and he's like i can't defeat this person
by myself i need scarlet witch i don't
need wanda maxum off i need scarlet
witch that's right so that could be like
he's like probability
like he sees all the different routes it
could take and be like i can only defeat
this thing
if you're scarlet witch not if you're
right yeah he needs
not someone who can just do like uh red
wiggly blues
but he needs a scarlet witch who has
absorbed all of agatha's collected magic
and then he would know that she read the
book and
not to shame dr strange but he had to do
all that stuff in his sleep she's
consciously walking around
drinking and doing a bunch of stuff so
he probably is like
i know how strong you are like i'm aware
of it you read the book
um though it's evil you read the book
so that definitely could be a
probability that could absolutely happen
um i think we came with a good answer
for that one for now uh as much of an
answer as we could what's our next
wizard the
wizard did they troll us by casting evan
pierce
yeah yeah so a lot of you guys keep
asking about this we want to include it
because it's an important one we did
i did talk about this in monday's video
uh uh
matt shachman did say on kevin smith and
mark bernardin's uh podcast that it was
kind of a mix of a lot of things
he wrote it off it was um like a meta
joke but he also
they wanted an alternate pietro instead
of aaron taylor johnson
in a way to reflect wanda's grief and
how grief can kind of
twist your worldview that way which i
get the emotional thing of that i think
what they're afraid to say is that oh we
just thought it would be a joke that you
would like and now that
they realize it confused fans more than
it uh
you know blew their minds in a good way
they're kind of weirdly backpedaling
into these other experiences they're
back pedaling and i i'm i'm i'm like go
i do you because i would have done the
same thing i would have gone on a
podcast
it'd been like let me air out what
happened you guys
even if it seems like i'm bringing up
stuff that doesn't need to be
said like they definitely are back by
lane i understand completely
that podcast episode made me feel better
about the
ending episode yeah me too and i think
what's hard about this
is like uh in my opinion as as much as
you and i love like looking into
interviews and
and seeing like q and a's with the
filmmakers a good piece of art should
not
need additional explanation in a podcast
q a
all answers should be uh satisfying
enough
to an audience just for watching it i
assume a lot of people are satisfied
enough with the one division
i feel i was satisfied enough where i
didn't need him to explain it but to
know that there was a 10th episode and
they couldn't do it
was enough for me to be like oh we
probably would have got
a little bit more figured out
by then so i'm sorry and then they were
he was also like
the first three episodes were supposed
to premiere that quickly
and i was like right i was like
that that's what that sucks i get you i
get you on that i think what he was
doing there is he's kind of signaling to
people who are still
disappointed or confused that look this
could have been a lot worse
like the fact that it came together this
wall was a little miraculous was due to
the hard-working talent of everyone
uh and like yeah a lot got moved covet
delayed everything we had
yeah they had to reconfigure much of it
uh and he just finished
um like he locked in the finale like two
weeks ago
so they were editing these episodes as
they were coming out you know truly so i
i felt more impressed with matt
shakman's creation
after listening to that podcast i after
listening to it i was like oh yeah i
need to keep
in mind which i think all of us as fans
should is like covid did put a halt on
so much and like the effects it had in
entertainment
they they couldn't even afford to do
more vfx like that was where they were
just like
we don't have enough time we literally
have to do everything
so after that i was like oh yeah that's
true well and
kobe the fact that it delayed certain
things like
one division was supposed to be fourth
in the lineup the fact that it was first
and they just put a high high
expectation on everything in it
to answer every question and i don't
think they initially intended evan
peters thing to be more than just kind
of like a fun little thing that people
wouldn't take too seriously
i would argue maybe if it came up fourth
in the lineup people still probably
would have gone crazy over it
okay but that's why they tried to
prevent it from leaking is they
like they put clothes over this guy's
head
somehow it still got out and i think
once it happened they're like damn it
people are going to go crazy over this
and
read too much into they don't do
anything about it okay well
yeah let's get into the third one
because i am going to connect
it to the timeline and how that went
backward
so okay wizard was jimmy who's missing
person
i'm going to slightly tie this in i
think i still do think
after reading you guys tweets at me
messages to me i do
fairly believe that it could be ralph
still a different
still not not it's hard to explain not
necessarily
but like her husband it could still be
agnes husband not necessarily ralph we
just didn't
give the husband a husband name we just
said ralph whether it's like
an actual husband or a demon or a god or
whatever i still think that
character still exists and maybe is the
missing
person to attach to that i think the
missing person
will be featured in um and falcon and
winter soldier and that's what it has to
do with the timeline yes
so i was like there has to be a
connection with the winter soldier and
one division and when i say there has to
be i that's just how i speak there
doesn't have to be
but it would be like why wouldn't there
be right we want to all touch on
everything we want everyone to connect
slightly so i was like i pitched um long
ago that
are on rogue theory that i think they're
just gonna do the buddy cop thing
fighting crime and doing that with the
government and within the government
within the fbi the person the missing
person
is probably going to be featured in
falcon and winter soldier and that's
where that missing person was going to
go in one division because falcon and
winter soldier are supposed to come
first right
so if that person goes missing and then
it's in one division you're like oh it's
that person from winter soldier
so i think because they swapped it
they're like it's not gonna be that big
of a deal people just see falcon winter
soldier and be like
oh that's the guy from war division and
do you think that he this whoever this
dude is just ended up in new jersey and
he's somewhere in the background
maybe even if he's like i don't think
he's gonna be a big part of falcon and
winter soldier i think he's gonna be
like
he's gonna say like he's gonna be like
and this is my friend ralph not
exactly but like this is my friend
herbert or ralph or thomas or whoever
he's in charge of so and so and that
so-and-so is gonna be very important
and then he becomes a missing person oh
my god he's in west view
but i think that's where we're gonna see
him but you go you you go
i've i mean i've made a case against
ralph just because
uh it's there's so many weird things it
seems like the context of that scene was
like
he's just a dude he's not anyone more
important than what we're saying right
now
in this scene which i think that's what
disappointed people the fact that like
it was ralph boner it's a reference to
boner from growing pains and that's
that's all that was uh but i honestly
feel more that dennis the
pizza delivery guy slash mailman and the
hex he seems like and
now i think of it it's more an age thing
like
he seems like the age of a kind of guy
who has to go into federal witness
protection because he's too
he's risen up too high to be a witness
to testify against mafiosos
evan peters seems like a guy in his 30s
like it's
i i don't know a whole lot about the
world of witness protection
but normally it's like people who are
older who have risen high enough to get
dirt
on other people in organized crime to
bring them down
that's true you know that i i think
there's something sketchy about that
mailman
i am still on board he might be the
person in bucky and winter soldier in
the winter
or that's why i think don't shoot the
messenger was all about that
like don't shoot the messenger because
that's something you could imagine a guy
saying like don't shoot me don't shoot
me i'm just a messenger tony don't shoot
me
i want to hold on to the theory that he
might be if we combine our things and if
the mailman delivery guy
is in falcon and the winter soldier
and that and then we can connect the two
and be like that's why he was so
important
that's why he got all those one-liners
because he got too many
we can't just jump that he did he did
well also can't we say that this show
one of the great things about it was
they did
give a lot of love to the full
supporting cast like
herb got a lot of great lines dotty got
a lot of great lines the guy who played
jones
phil jones that's so funny like he got
so many good jokes
like the mustache everyone felt like
they played an important role it was
like uh
norm i forget the comedian's name he has
a tick tock account that's just about
him being like
i'm not going to spoil it for you yeah i
see this job
it's so funny i can't get a new job
during covent
oh yeah i can't do this he's like making
up lies he's like
i have to pay for my butt i live in l.a
well and i think we have to acknowledge
you know what what is the occam's razor
or this like
it might have just been a detail that
the writers just said well how do we get
jimmy wu in this
he fbi deals with missing people or they
deal with witness protection
so he just had someone and that's how he
meets monica rambo
and they never expected to be more than
that because that was the only time it
was brought up
right you just said it in that one scene
and we were all like
holy shirt and i don't think jimmy wu
ever again brings up he's like by the
way i'm still looking for my witness
yeah
yeah he's not going to bring it up in
doctor strange too he's like
is everyone seeing my boy my boy he's
missing
yeah i don't think so all right our our
next wizard the jessica
what's the happened to the rabbit senor
scratchy
this is something that we actually
covered in yesterday's video a little
bit
it comes at the very end of the podcast
matt shockman said that there was a
deleted scene
in which this rabbit was gonna be
revealed as agatha's familiar which you
know in witchcraft is like your animal
companion who helps you do evil [ __ ]
uh and that he was in charge of
protecting the darkhold and that when
the kids tried to go steal the darkhold
this rabbit would transform into a
monstrous demon american werewolf and
london style
and like the goonies chased them around
that dungeon
oh that would have been so fun but now
we know exactly what happened to senior
scratchy and what we were
slightly missing nothing and and i i'm a
fan who wants to see every deleted scene
of everything
you know and that's kind of a bummer
like a disney plus sometimes releases
deleted scenes but not always
and shackman said that the vfx wasn't
finished on this so i'm a good one
they could they could eventually one day
like if especially if like covet
is getting better it's lifting whatever
what have you if they have more time
money they could easily just add the vfx
because they already shot it
so they just need to do it in post you
know disney
plus when disney plus launched they did
have some
um mcu infinity saga deleted scenes they
had one from thor ragnarok
where it was like odin in like the
alleyway
and when the bifrost arrives there's
kind of some goofy derpy looking potato
uh like placeholder effects oh and then
in the scene where hulk hulk has a whole
deleted scene where
he um banner becomes hulk in infinity
war they don't delay it to end game
and they show a whole scene where they
had the computer generated
effects and like his arm is like uh
clipping through his legs
and they just have um ruffalo's
voiceover so they could release an
unfinished version of it and that's what
i want to see
they could just you just have to give it
time as much as
end game did that with disney plus i
don't
think i don't know i didn't see whatever
cut matt chapman's looking at the guy's
a good storyteller i trust him as a
director
if he said it need to go i i believe him
but
it also doesn't seem like it was gonna
be that important it was more so just
for like
we would have seen like oh senior
scratchy but it doesn't seem like it's a
it's okay that we lost it right right i
think
uh i think for most people they could
just kind of surmise that it was
familiar maybe shaq was like i'll just
go on a podcast and just tell people
what i originally wanted
he just told everything yeah he assumed
rightly that most viewers wouldn't
really care
so i think a lot of viewers ended that
episode and didn't really think hey
where was that rabbit i think a lot of
us did but most didn't i think i did
i did too it was like crazy because that
rabbit tell me where that rabbit went it
ate that bird
i keep bringing that up and people are
like it turned back into a fly and i'm
like i don't care
there was a female that came out of its
mouth it was a bird
i saw it consume it either way it
consumes something too
fast rabbits eat cobb salads they eat
cobb salad you're right
cobb salads damn it not birds and they
and when they eat cops out they pick
around the bacon
and the they're better they better they
better
not leave uh wizard the was the
aerospace engineer
and if it wasn't anyone special why did
the show make it such a big deal
i know i know and i gotta say shackman i
don't think is a very good answer for
this
yeah i wanted it to be to build up to
monica's rover sequence he's always
he's like i spent all this time on this
and i assumed by rover sequence i
thought he's just talking about
the the rover just rolling out in front
of it but no i think he also means
monica
pushing through pushing through which i
one of my favorite scenes in the whole
it was great but we were looking for the
aerospace engineer we weren't yeah the
scene it doesn't take away from the
scene if you would have put that in
there and then also her going through
the hex i would have been like these are
both two great scenes
instead you kind of just lied to us
or just like i don't think he properly
expected it's not just him it's the
writer it's the editor it's everyone who
worked on it
they they include these close-ups of
monica writing on a phone but wouldn't
show us who she was talking
show me that screen dang it and i think
uh really just talk about major goodner
major goodner was that actually
at least that's what shaqman implied is
the actress who played manager goodner
that he really likes
was that person but like why would they
not just say
like hey i got another contact named
major goodner who's going to help me
with this
why did they build that up to be a
mystery i have no idea
i really i really don't want to believe
in storytelling
line they thought like two positives
make a negative
like not in like in such a weird way i
don't
like i'm not a great storyteller but i
would know not to do that if i wrote it
to be like
right um oh you're gonna go see the air
engineer
psych i want you to see this woman
change
or turn into a hex and it's like but you
lured me here with something else
see and i think that might have been
part of it sounds like a lot
of the real world stuff was reconfigured
a lot of the the tiana
paris scenes the uh cat denning scenes
at randall park scenes they might have
re-edited a lot of that stuff
exactly and that was just something some
kind of weird configuration of that is
what we saw
and then after it came out shakman's
like oh no they're taking away the wrong
thing from this no
i said look at her and i'm like but
who's the engineer
i'm like is it reid richards you know
we're crazy
you know what it is it honestly is he
has such a moving target
everyone who makes these marvel movies
it's like your audience is insane it's
insane
don't put it do you need to spell it out
to us unless you want us to like assume
this tissue box
is a front it's something else we're
talking a conspiracy thing
tim lives in it there's a mansion in
there it's just small
right right right right oh literally but
one we're still waiting for an answer
for
a wizard happened to that beekeeper and
why did he turn to a beekeeper to begin
with people
are still upset about the beekeeper
they're still on that bee
that was like episode two or three
two that was so long ago it feels like
yeah so
i think what we've been saying kind of
the whole time we never did see him
expel but presumably he just got
expelled when wanda said no and reversed
it and that reversed him walking out
that doesn't mean he's still
reversing through his whole life though
i do love that idea they're like why is
this guy
tenating back to high school and why is
he
he was in 10th grade last year and now
he's in nineteen jeff where are you
going i gotta go
is this right i got blue
we don't know what's going on with him
but he likes to scat they're like that's
not scatty
i don't know he's like a world famous
scatter this little boy is such a good
scout such a good guy and he's just
getting
younger by the day it is kind of
annoying that they never went back to
him but he's probably just like
in the um the health like where wanda
was when she came back he probably
went back in there and was just being
also worked on and was like
how do you remember anything that
happened in there i think he was
yeah he was in that sword camp somewhere
and
uh eventually he was turned into a
carney when that warped into a yeah
into a carnival he went from a beekeeper
to a carny
the only life i want but why was he
changing to a beekeeper
i don't know i think it was the suit
i think it was just he was wearing a
suit and they're like what's another
non-military non-radiation based
kind of covering that you can wear that
is just more
domestic in a way and it's like oh a
beekeeper yeah and honestly that's the
closest thing you can do other than aim
uh which aim wasn't a part of it i
yeah have died on that hill see you died
on them
which is more well the messel hill is
more realistic than me being like
looks like swarms coming in same look
it's aiming and swarm they're both
coming in
we got more nazis come on we got more
nazis uh but before we continue we want
to thank some friends who helped make
this episode thank you to stereo new
rockstars
is excited to partner with the stereo
app for a whole lineup of weekly live
shows
download the stereo app for free at
stereo.com new rockstars
our schedule is slightly different this
week as we have some new projects
starting so
you're going to want to make sure to
follow the new rockstars account on
stereo and check the uh
upcoming events so you don't miss
anything this week you're going to hear
some new voices
as well as uh get a sneak peek at the
falcon the winter soldier
on all of our stereo shows you can
interact with us through voice
submissions and hear your questions
answered live on the show
hearing from you all has been the best
part of doing these shows and some of
you are super funny and you have some
great great theories you can hear
previous episodes of any of these shows
on the stereo app
access these live shows share your
questions and theories and interact with
us in real time by downloading the free
stereo app
at stereo dot com slash new rockstars at
stereo dot com new rockstars
support for inside marvel is brought to
you by manscape the best in men's below
the way screw mean
manscaped offers precision engineered
tools for your family jewels they've got
the best tech to trim below the deck
i love it when it rhymes uh manscaped is
trusted by over
2 million men worldwide i mean we didn't
have a wolverine cameo in wan division
but if hugh jackman had popped up he
would have been beautifully groomed
and not with those dangerous adamantium
claws
because they'll slice off anything they
touch the manscape has redesigned the
electric chair mirror
the manscaped engineering team spent 18
months perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created the lawnmower 3.0
their third generation trimmer features
a cutting edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooving accidents thanks to advanced
skin safe technology pioneered by
manscaped the battery will last
up to 90 minutes and waterproof
technology allows you to groom in the
shower
experience it firsthand for yourself get
20 off
plus free shipping with the code
onedivisionmanscape.com your balls will
thank you
get 20 off from free shipping with the
code onedivisionmanscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping on manscape.com
and using code wandavision we also want
to thank our friends at magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode lots of us are
trying to eat better but healthy
breakfast doesn't have to be boring
magic spoon is the flavors you love
without all the bad stuff each serving
has zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein four net grams
of carbs and only 140 calories a
serving it's keto friendly gluten free
grain grain-free soy free low-carb gmo
free
get yourself a variety pack of four
flavors cocoa fruity frosted and peanut
butter
go to magicspoon.com marvel to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code marvel
at checkout to save five dollars off
your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product and it's packed with a 100
happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com marvel and used to go
marvel to save five dollars off and
thank you to magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
all right jessica back to our uh wtf's
wizard did wanda unleash
there's two ways this could go in my
book so one
she could have just unleashed what we
said what i said earlier i think we both
agree
uh all the portals and like just
releasing like different portals around
the globe or universe that are like
the um releasing the multiverse so
different
dimensions right ultimately b she if she
was a wonder gorm
okay so what if she was at that mountain
right what if she had to be closer to
that mountain
because that's where the book came from
because of the
demon i'm not going to say the demon's
name after you tweeted about the demon's
name i'm too afraid to say the demon's
name
you say it three times they'll appear
again say his name just ugh
i was like i don't want to say it
because i know i'm going to butcher it
but
yeah so someone responded in a great way
that
it's based on cthulhu and human uh vocal
chords
and mouths cannot pronounce it otherwise
he would go insane if we did pronounce
it correctly okay so i can't pronounce
it correctly because i'm not insane
and watch me pronounce it correctly but
what if she unleashed
that the demon or she unleashes mephisto
so i'm like there i think it's one of
the one of the two she either really
unleashed a demon or she unleashed just
portals over the world releasing
different people from different
dimensions because that would be
reason for why we're going to get doc
ock in spider-man far no way home right
because yeah that could be one way if
they do make it an actual multiverse
thing rather than he was just there
the whole time confusing is there is a
rumor that that's what the i just
assumed that we weren't going to bring
him back because he was dead no the idea
was like uh jamie foxx is going to be
playing a green and yellow suited
electro who wasn't the dr manhattan
looking electro from amazing spider-man
2. so if that's the case it's just a
different version of a lecture that's in
the mcu oh so he's just a different
doctor more confusing to me honestly
than pulling from the multiverse but
so much more confusing yeah um i don't
fully know i but i agree with you i
think one of these demons is what she
unleashed and that would make
sense for agatha not being a villain
going forward but she's afraid of what's
beyond
i don't think agatha's a villain anymore
i don't think she's a villain
the only people kind of one of these
neutrals i love her more that way
yeah i truly was like after thinking
about it and what she was saying too
i was like yeah wait no wanda you were
doing the bad stunts
she didn't put those people in that coma
she didn't like take over this
right she especially when she snapped
that cord i was like damn you harsh
agatha but then i was like
nah she literally just let someone free
like
yeah yeah
which is all about agatha what happens
to agatha now and uh jess
do you think she stays in the trance as
agnes after wanda ends the hex
absolutely i think she's gonna stay in
west uh west view
yeah it's still the town's west view
it's not made up um i think she's gonna
stay in that town the thing that's funny
about me
thinking that she's gonna stay in that
town is how her neighbor's not gonna
recognize her as that
flying witch that was fighting wanda in
the sky earlier
and they're gonna be okay with it but i
think she's gonna stay in west view as
the nosy happy neighbor
but because she was dressed like today's
neighborly like
woman so i think she's just gonna stay
there until
like she said until i need you so i
think she's gonna stay there and the
wand is gonna go back
take her out of her hex like mine field
and be like yo i need you to tell me how
to use your powers correctly like i've
been
spraying bullets all over the place or
something right
i think uh i think that's part of the
why the residents of west view were so
resentful to wanda other than the fact
that she like mind controlled them
right after the traumatic blip had
happened yeah so trauma to trauma back
to you
so they're already but they they glared
at her she walked out and i think agatha
might have been part of that because she
left agatha there
as a way to kind of send a message to
the others like i can do this to all of
you anytime i want
even though she doesn't want to she
feels apologetic to them
but to them they have this creepy ass
witch who lives up in this house up on
the hill
they tell their kids to stay the hell
away from her because she's just a crazy
like hi
doesn't someone want to come to my
cookoff and they're like
[ __ ] no we stand away from you and the
witch
please and they they all
keep their distance because they this
woman is uh evidence of this weird
witch battle that happened a couple
months ago absolutely that what i mean
that's a reason for me to be quiet as a
neighbor but i just don't want to be
involved
i already got my mind suppressed and my
child was locked in my room like i don't
want that to happen again
so i i do think agatha i i am going on
right or
like me myself saying agatha isn't the
villain anymore and that's more reason
to keep her in the mcu going forward
is because she's not like you can't
really keep like an
[ __ ] on the good person's side for
long so i think she's gonna stay as like
look if you need my help i guess i gotta
help you like i don't yeah
i think she's gonna be like uh did uh
did you ever watch the soap opera
uh passions no i only watched like one
soap opera
oh there is a soap opera with a witch in
it
um okay well look i'm already into it
yeah okay it's called passions i only
know about this
because my sister got a job one summer
and she was obsessed with the show my
older sister
and she's like i will pay you three
bucks a day
if you take passions for me while i'm at
my job so i'd be like fine and i'd put
it in and i would end up watching this
show and i got sucked into passions
there is a witch in passions who
uh brings like a a doll to life
and it's just this whole other side plot
that doesn't at
all affect like the drama the
relationship drama and i think that's
what agatha is gonna be in the mcu
they're gonna be like hey let's check in
with that witch over there and she's
like
i'm just talking to my dolls leave me
alone i'm just talking to my dolls
they're like hey i just need to borrow
like a cup of sugar i know you can make
that appear magically so it just sounds
like going to the store you just help me
out she's like bruce banner you're
gaining weight i'm not giving you any of
this i'm not giving you anything bruce
banner
oh god i hope that's who she's going to
be in the future i just want agatha to
be a witch
i want actually she's gonna witch do you
think she lost
all of her powers no i think she's still
got some i think she's still got a
little bit like she can do little things
like she can make things float
but definitely sweet things control a
human again
oh was it the happened to the twins
yeah so i think these twins never
existed to begin with
that's my theory i think these twins
were always
a piece of demonic magic that
uh was used to trick wanda through
outside forces from the darkhold
because wanda at the end says thank you
for letting me be
thank you for choosing me to be your mom
wanda
kind of create but watch wanda and
vision obviously didn't conceive these
kids normally right
it's implied that they fooled around but
vision's a robot
he can't conceive children wanda we
didn't see wanda create these kids the
way she created vision
so i think these kids were tricks that
came from and they weren't fully fleshed
out characters right they were kind of
these ideal versions
and i think for the purposes of this in
the hex they were sweet boys who wanted
wanda's help or wanted to help wanda in
their dad vision
but i think their voice is screaming
from the dark hold at the end
i think that was the voice of whatever
demon
you want to be in these things i think
they're i think they're the voice that
was the voice of mephisto
in that moment i could see that i could
see that i i could see the
the ending part i really have a hard
time believing that those kids were like
they were there but they weren't real
they were there as much as vision was
there you know
not as much as vision was there i think
uh they were
like because they weren't created by her
magic you know
they were pulled through some other
means do you think not that's
this ties in with our next what wander
the feet of this on yeah
but i think i think these boys are a
demon spawn
uh and i think that was just they are
gonna eventually bring in this thing of
mephisto
has pieces of his soul that are that
like at some point later in the future
wanda's gonna be like then what were my
sons and dr strange is gonna be like
sit down honey there's a demon and he
keeps doing that you're not the only one
he's done this to
he does to a lot of people but he makes
people think they have kids and they're
that way we're not actually seeing the
process of these kids being evaporated
and sucked into the skin of a demon yeah
that makes sense
because we didn't even see them like die
oh i think we might still see that i
mean these
two actors one of these actors just
tweeted me it was so cool uh i was so
flattered
yeah uh uh julian hilliard uh who played
billy uh was so sweet
and he said i'm sorry i wasn't mephisto
all along
but i'm like not a clue not a clue he
was just being nice
oh god a little baby yeah but he was
like uh yeah i think these kids might be
in multiverse of madness and that whole
story can get shown there
well this is the thing that's going to
piss me off about the casting because i
was like looking at the casting for
doctor strange too and i was like how
many of these people are just going to
be like
flashbacks i hope they wouldn't do that
but i was like
watch them be flashbacks for wanda and
that's why they're like credited
as cast in the movies and i'm gonna be
like yeah i'm gonna see i think the kids
is how wanda gets lured into the
multiverse of madness she's gonna go on
a chase to try to find these kids in
different realities yeah i think when
really once she finds them
they're gonna be a snare and uh
mephisto's gonna rope her in
real talk look real quick or speculative
talk
and we'll see i've been wrong before
folks i'll be wrong again
i'll be wrong again but let's talk about
our next wisdom
what was for the children about they
said for the children did this come from
wanda or did it come from agatha who was
making these people chant for the
children
i think it was coming from wanda since
she still had a rope on those
people i understand where i could come
from agatha because she's just like
oh i'm getting bored with this jeep like
fast forward
i need you to tell me where you got
these powers but i think it's wanda
because she is going through the steps
of like what a normal housewife does in
those like
old television shows so they're like she
consciously or like
deep in her mind knew that it was time
to have a child soon
so yeah because agatha clearly didn't
really need or want those kids for
anything
yeah oh yeah she did she just wanted
wanda's chaos magic that's it
so then so you're right yeah it would it
would have been wanda not agatha
there is a theory that it could have
just been like a natural thing that the
townspeople of begging wanted to free
their children that's so sad
that's super sad but dottie was like
i'll have my kid do any storyline you
want you know that was
when that scene i was like wanda you
locked them in a bedroom
i was are they eating what are they
doing how are they consuming food
do they use the bathroom that's why i
think wanda is the villain
like she doesn't have to be like a
villain villain but like it's definitely
not agatha
yeah you're right agatha didn't lock up
children she didn't well she choked out
too but they weren't real
so it's like that's right yeah [ __ ]
exactly exactly now uh we should move on
we have a bit of time left we want to
talk about what are the
with those purple vines going down in
the ag space when did agatha set up that
whole dungeon because it wasn't her
house it was
ralph's house she just took so how did
she have time to build all that was it
just with magic
you think jess she just has magic well
owning the house or the vinings
all of it i i at first was on your i was
on board with you saying that these were
the
flowers from wonder gore or yeah so i
was like yeah this could seem true
but i also think out of just a witch
aesthetic
it's just the powers of like like if it
wasn't
it's like hard to explain but like if it
wasn't if it was a different witch maybe
it would have been moss
if they're like forest kind of witches
if it was like uh
the metal it would be like someone that
did witchcraft here in town i don't know
it's hard to explain it's so weird it's
such craft kind of [ __ ]
but um which is a good movie from the
90s but are you saying some witches use
different kinds of
yeah i think they like learn different
things and i use
mushrooms okay shut up
yeah it just sprouted mushrooms she's
like go ahead take a bite
it's the poison that killed spicy the
creamy yeah
many many recipes i can make with my
mushrooms
where's my kid's mushroom witch she's
like oh i didn't want that nickname
um but i think hers was just like
because she was like when she was about
to get killed in the forest
it gave off that same vibe of her
basement where it was like we're in the
forest we're in the dark and the vines
are her color are her purple so i think
it was just like as her powers grew the
vines reached
so that's why it was like all over the
place but i bet at first it was just
like
oozy and weird in the middle of the
cellar
i think like the implication of the
ending of episode seven the beginning of
episode eight is that
this witch just set up shop and like she
uses these runes
this uh like when that whole uh
journey through the past ended wanda was
in a studio
a studio set and then when she left
through those doors she was outside
one she was outside against this house
kind of like willy wonka door style
so like yeah this whole house is kind of
hexed in a weird way and that's part of
maybe it's just some witch spell where
it's like once you set up residence
you can set it up with your weird
satanic stuff literally and she's a
witch so it's definitely like
i'm gonna bring my tent that has my
entire home in it
i'm just like hermione hermione did that
i needed that oh yes
i'm the grandma from halloween town she
pulled balloons out of her purse i'm
sure she could
marry poppins mary poppins pulling [ __ ]
out
witches have traits which is
witches know how to travel let me tell
you right now
they can pack a bag they don't gotta
check anything
because they can fight yeah so our uh
final wtf before we talk about some
devil's stuff what
was the deal with the cicadas
so do we have an answer there was it
just sounds thing
people are connecting the like fly and
mephisto still so if you want to ride
that i would understand
i think it was just to show that like
look at the magic i can do and if it
wasn't a cicada it would have been like
a moth if it wasn't a moth it would have
been
oh yeah it was to demonstrate her
animal transfiguration but also to set
up
the senior scratchy rabbit to eat yes so
they needed
a way to for tell that thing being a
carnivorous beast
so that in the finale episode when that
crazy scene happens they're like oh he
ate those bugs
uh so it's just a show like a food chain
absolutely
absolutely they needed a fly that was
large enough to where we heard a crunch
of that rabbit eating it
oh yeah they were like what insect makes
a large enough crunch that's not a roach
but flies like a roach and they're like
a cigarette
and that's okay that's kind of like a
moth that uh i feel like that moment was
a silence of the lambs thing of wanda
looking at the curtains
being like whoa like yeah
they're gonna just making making choices
all right one final what the
devil what the devil
when will mephisto appear jess do you
think it'll be a loki multiverse madness
moon night midnight suns blade ghost
rider
never never i think it will i pitched
doctor strange
too i think it would but what is the
timeline again
you tell me this every time but the
timeline of when the movies are coming
out so we have
we finished one division we have uh
falcon winner soldier
taco winner soldier and then we have uh
black widows still tendedly scheduled
for may but we have uh
loki in june yes then we have what if
and then we have hawkeye and miss marvel
are coming in the fall
we have shang chi over the summer in
july we have
eternals coming in november we got a
full thing before and then
we have spider-man uh no way home coming
in december and then
in january of 2022 we could be seeing
moon knight and or she-hulk around that
time um
but in march will be multiverse of
madness followed by thor
love and thunder in may well hopefully
they push it up now at first i was like
i don't think they're gonna push it up
but now i'm like okay i think they need
to push it up
so my theory that methista will show up
in it makes more sense
i think would still make sense even if
it's uh way far away and because i mean
i don't think
whatever wanda's problem is will
manifest in multiverse of madness and i
think we can have patience until then
they wouldn't make him the like big
villain right
i think the big villain will be like
wanda because like
i'm not saying it has to be the
equivalent to thanos i'm just saying
like
you gotta for me as a fan you have to
give me something bigger than that
so what you're gonna might have a member
of your own team that is unstoppable
and i've always thought we don't
necessarily need a villain
uh in this uh like a you know capital v
villain we could see a relationship
between doctor strange and wanda as kind
of a a
doctor a pat a doctor a healer and a
patient
yeah and it's just kind of like this
badass therapy scene where they're like
in a wizard duel the whole time
but he's really just trying to heal her
and help her yeah helped
so it's not like a story about like
pixar's old rules
uh was that they weren't gonna have any
obvious villains to the plot
uh so like if you go back to toy story
sid is kind of a villain but he's not
like
the structural villain of the story
woody is kind of the antagonist of that
story
you know he's not he's kind of a jerk uh
but then he learns to change and to
accept newcomers
um and i think good stories do that uh
and
marvel is kind of evolving to the point
to where they don't need a villain in
every story
true so this is just one where they're
like trying to like help her
trying to break it down and she's just
not like either listening or just like i
don't know how
that would be nice right another so i
think we might get a glimpse of
loki in uh we might get a glimpse of of
machisto and loki
um but i think uh if he does show up
it's gonna be in multiverse of madness
if not there it's gonna be sometime
away in the future uh when ghost rider
needs to show up because
but this is part of ghost writers yeah
if
it shows up in loki i don't think it's
gonna be a heavy-handed thing i think
it's more so
just an easter egg yeah a little bit
we're gonna get a little taste
a little taste it has to be him because
ah how are you gonna do ghost rider i
know you did one division without like i
guess
magneto yet but like uh ghostwriter you
kind of have to bring mephisto in
so yeah i mean one already exists in the
mcu so they were just able to kind of
reframe
some of the story we already saw but
yeah ghost rider
if you introduce some cold turkey yeah
you're gonna need a real hot turkey down
below to come down you're gonna
bring nicolas cage with you oh yes
oh my gosh no thank you um
well one last reminder to download the
stereo app by going to stereo dot com
new rockstar so you can listen to our
weekly live shows you can submit
questions and theories and hear us
respond in real time download the app
for free on apple and android and create
an avatar profile
but that is a wrap on this one division
after show
just what a ride it has been
it has been so fun you are so funny
it went quick but it also like took its
time because every week
i was like okay well i can't wait for
one division can't wait for one of which
and
when the turns over i was like oh my
gosh it's done oh yeah
it is fun but you know what inside
marvel will live on with after shows for
the falcon the winter soldier i know
a lot of you have been asking about it
and i can now announce that we are
adding another member to the new
rockstars family to co-host it with me
mt mastertainment but that doesn't mean
jessica's going away
jessica and i are going to continue to
chat about it elsewhere on the channel
uh jessica is gonna be a regular face
you're gonna see her on uh it's a marvel
big uh question
on rogue theory on all kinds of
different formats we have
so uh essentially nothing is ending only
new things are beginning only new
of people coming to this party uh so
everyone's still here
love wait what is what is goodbye
without love what is the quote
yeah what is uh goodbye if not hello
persevering
yeah if that hello persevering i
watched our show look i watched
wandavision i watched a lot of it
i did well uh be sure to follow jess at
lulu underscore clemens on twitter you
can follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
thank you all so much for watching
goodbye
a muppet that is waiting can i top your
muppet uh ranking
you're number one yay
edit this out don't put this
there they'll be like
[Music]
you